and Rick Williams with the field-goal
here's Kevin Knox Oprah Williamson and
he splashes one hold knocks laying off
Williamson now who shoots an air ball up
along to and then knocks sprinting the
floor gets himself to the deep corner
quick release on the jump shot he's made
two of those now three are inside
against Jackson Knox looking for his
third three boy that thing's wet right
in the middle of the desert the ability
to rise and fire off the bounce by
Jackson Jackson a guy that was injured
last year this time Kevin Knox with a
nice layup you know there's best with
poor on the shot clock
Dawkins for the long two partially
blocked by Knox Vincent a real force in
the paint throughout the regular season
for the Knicks Knox hit his first three
threes hits his first one here tonight
averaged 15.3 points per game 37%
three-point shooting Knox great time
inside and the flush by Mitchell
Robinson express herself Ashley Dunn he
attacks the closeout draws the second
defend not just the distance it's with
small window to make it knocks on the
drive
[Applause]
not to new supplies see an ally
go ahead he curls makes a nice play I'll
get a free throw yeah and actually has
some family and Brooklyn on his mother's
side of the family Kevin Knox in a nice
blue from behind the three-point line
the Knicks in the middle of a 12 nothing
run can connect with young players and
mentor and teach on cue beginning to the
Vegas summer league through two games
here from Alpharetta Georgia
Mitchell Robinson with the steal merit
to Knox they did not poo this year's
pick of our Jay Baer then three ball is
good for Dean Allen the Knicks have made
five of the last six shots after missing
on seven of their first date Knox hits a
three as the next day hop here got a
stroke Dwane Casey coach of the year one
with Nick nurse acquired Kawhi Leonard
and then they got a chance to win I
think also people don't talk about
Smitty here's Knox defended from behind
the bounds came back in established
himself and it definitely hit it off
glass here's Knox coming back for New
York he scores plus the foul impressive
he loved this but Knox is six you're in
business
tough shot no good here comes to deem
Allen up to Kevin Knox he's got not the
quick starts at his games and continues
to do so here that's his second field
goal
earn on coaches appreciation day this is
a move that any coach would love back
after this
it is absolutely spectacular done some
major upgrades Lila
Kevin Knox nice grip move couldn't
finish did on the second attempt Kevin
Knox looking very aggressive free throws
should be the thing shoot off of that
and he'll be spot Kevin Knox drills the
three him in my kins I'm what you think
I mean Frank Frank Vogel mentioned pay
cocked in the end of this edition
Mitchell Robinson real pogo stick inside
just getting the lane bad things are
gonna happen for you defensively and
when you help up take him among the top
five guys to shoot the ball at the end
of the game he was a clutch guy in the
tournament against Ohio State against
UNC Wilmington I take him to make some
shots to he not bad once the regular
season starts regardless of the Miss New
York with it win I love his don't want
to be a player no more that's one of my
favorite jams you're not a player you
just crush a lot I just crushed a lot
man once he sees a South Florida
resident now you know now you're an 11
points to the game hit 1 3 now here at
14 get it offensive rebound now you're
at 16 to the steel in the layup Dyer
Nate I mean you don't have to make a ton
of shots and another outstanding
the girl down
be my contact yes we didn't know the
next generation will be the Tristan
Thompson the are gay bear a wig and so
forth and so on and you look at all the
Canadian players that's all about it
means there's a time for finesse but if
you're attacking the raft
here's Knox for three today he's got a
great Sobers Dacus in and Kavanagh goes
out knots and knots took it away
Knox finding and ruling for the finish a
[Applause]
look ahead [ __ ] Knox disrupted that
just enough the people that come in the
building is really what makes that build
insane and makes it hum Knoxville
[Applause]
good one-on-one defense by oxana
rejection picked up by passion eeks
trying to get their second win here at
some early nights pitches it out fresh
Davis for three
[Applause]
57 for the game great fine by Knox Bros
Degas uncovered in the corner for three
must-see TV Memphis Tigers Knox Rises
Barrett for three what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content